[Musique]
mons a été magistral dans ma bouche à
moi ça fait waouh c'est justement puis
depuis ce temps là je l'utiliser partout
le chef pascal lafon de lanaudière est
très enthousiaste lorsqu'il parle de
l'huile de caméline est un bond majeur
dans tous les restos tous les chefs se
l'arrachent ben en fait c'est nul est à
mon sens qui est unique
vraiment et c'est une huile qu'on
produit en petite quantité à matane en
gaspésie à saskatoon dans l'ouest
canadien et à saint-édouard en
montérégie
la caméline fait des belles tout
l'argent qui laisse place à des petits
grains c'est ce petit grain là qu'on
vient récolter avec des moissonneuses
batteuses et qu'on emmène dans des silos
et après ça on pressent ce grain la fois
un précieux et embouteillées ça goûte le
vert
le gazon fraîchement coupé sa goutte à
goutte
la nature parce qu'elle nous propose une
recette toute simple pour réveiller nos
papilles au goût surprenant de la
caméline petit la cameline terrasse
couvert du rapido donc puis un petit
frère de celle une bonne au japon puis
on fait juste rampe et soeurs puis on
déguste donc c'est pas trop fort mais
vous venez gré aussi bien un peu atténué
le vert du bus on peut dire ouais
le chef nous étonne en mariant caméline
f
en fait les oeufs brouillés avec un bar
style fermiers donc je vais refuser mon
beurre avec du foin pour aller chercher
les mêmes notes herbacées gazon que la
cameline les graines de cameline voici
donc l ensemble on aura un peu de
croquant un peu le moelleux a pu
assister
qu'est ce que tu me conseille de faire
un amalgame de tout ça de se boucher ou
de crème sur la petite graine
grillez 7 x 2 x turkcell est possible
mais il faut s'amuser avec les boppoises
youtube ce qui ce qui démarque la grande
de caméline c'est pour une cuillère à
table de graines de caméline on retrouve
quatre grammes de fibres 4 g de
protéines et 1.5 g domino 3 mais c'est
pour son goût que jonathan lapierre chef
au restaurant de l'ithq a eu un coup de
foudre pour la graine de caméline ça me
fait de plus en plus le cas le seul
avant de lancer que sur elle au québec
soit ce qui pose autour de nous ça nous
identifient permis de remplacer beaucoup
le pavot la graine de sésame souvent non
pour beaucoup de cette pièce conscience
accrue la graine ou full affaires retire
un peu cru avant l'essai comme lui et la
voir les arts ont un peu plus vert mais
une fois qu'ils ratissent a pu se
transformer par le côté nous en
noisettes
j'aime beaucoup la terrifier un peu
c'est dans cette optique que jonathan de
cuisine un poisson en coûte en
l'esbrouffe les temps dans le temps
pleine saison c'est qu'on me prouve le
fait tant de grains de gamme les mecs un
peu de fleur de sel
on cuit dans l'huile de cameline pour
les filles aux fausses l'épaisse arrêtés
sont pas sont ils vraiment une grosse
épaisseur plus nous faut ce nom à la
peau pendant que le flétan cuit le chef
nous propose la tuile une belle option
pour goûter davantage les graines de
caméline où se craqueler qu'on peut
manger qu'une salade quatre ingrédients
graines de caméline au fait qu est ce l
on porte à ébullition en étant et on
enfourne
belle dentelle belle torréfaction que
c'est fait puisque téléphone le côté
quasiment oignons school écosphère qu'on
parlait montano nyon qui en tant que
là-dessus ça c'est intéressant d'autant
plus que c'est relativement simple à
faire à la main et que dire de notre
flétan pierre de bois qui sont pas nés
d'un côté un côté points avec leurs
canines pour renforcer le goût un
colloque le moyeu du poisson le
croustillant de la gloire d'un jeu
texture quand bart là dessus et la
caméline se serrent même au dessert
plein de chocolat blanc ou à l'huile de
cameline avec suprême de citron vert
confie ont rajouté petites îles de l'est
là dessus et puis
on va s'amuser de joyeuses complexité
embauché comme sens à sa vie
de belles découvertes
la caméline en huile ou en grain un
produit d'ici à découvrir
j'adore vraiment ce que je suis je suis
et passionné de services personnalisés
la caméline est riche en oméga 3 et son
point de fumée et elvis car fait une
excellente huile pour la cuisson